just for a get stones that I do wanna
mention another channel that I host
called mega-projects it's a channel all
about mankind's greatest achievements or
potential future achievements where I
take a deep look at incredible buildings
projects structures and more whether
it's the world's most impressive
skyscrapers the International Space
Station or Chernobyl sarcophagus I cover
it all new videos come out a couple of
times a week on mega projects so if you
think it could be for you head on over
and subscribe there is a link in the
description below and let's get into it
[Music]
in his abit shuri The New York Times
called Robert Franklin Stroud probably
America's most famous convict he rose to
notoriety late in life after author and
former corrections officer Thomas Z
Gaddis wrote a book about him in 1955
titled Birdman of Alcatraz a few years
later this turned into a movie of the
same name starring Burt Lancaster in the
title role this was a major Hollywood
production which proved popular with
moviegoers in critics and received four
Academy Award nominations both the movie
and the book were instrumental in
shaping the persona of the Birdman of
Alcatraz that the American public came
to know and even admire in both the
movie in the book Robert Stroud was
portrayed in a positive even heroic
light here was a self-taught man of
superior intellect with a lot to offer
who did something bad once but was ready
and willing to make it up to society
this view although it turned Robert
Stroud's into a media sensation did not
line up with reality at least not
according to the guards and inmates who
actually knew him once said that he was
not a sweetheart like the Birdman in the
movie and that Burt Lancaster owes us
all an apology others said that the real
Stroud was a vicious killer or a guy
that liked chaos and turmoil the doctor
who did his official psychiatric
evaluation in 1943 concluded that Stroud
was a psychopath with an IQ of 112
clearly there is a lot more to the tale
of the Birdman of Alcatraz than what has
been publicized and today we're gonna
try and get the real story
Robert Franklin Stroud was born on
January the 28th 1890 in Seattle
Washington Benjamin Franklin Stroud and
Elizabeth Jane McCartney not much is
known about his childhood he had a
younger brother and two older
stepsisters from his mother's previous
marriage life at home was not a happy
one because Ben Stroud was an alcoholic
and an abuser and his children were
often the target of his rage when he was
13 Robert Stroud had had enough of his
father's persecution so he ran away from
home he drifted from one place to
another for a few years before
eventually making his way to the Alaska
territory when he was 18 at first he
found an honest job working on a
railroad gang this kept him on the move
and he ended up in the town of Cordova
there he met an older woman named Kitty
O'Brien who had worked as a dancehall
entertainer and an occasional prostitute
Stroud began serving as her pimp
although the exact nature of their
relationship is still up for debate some
say that it was strictly professional
while others believed that the two were
romantically involved either way they
spent a lot of time together and in 1908
they decided to relocate Juneau which
back then was a booming gold town it was
here that Robert Stroud first started to
show his violent nature he became angry
with an acquaintance of his bartender
identified as Charlie van Dahmer or de
Mer the exact problem is uncertain some
sources say that van Dahmer beat up
kitty Oh Brad others that he refused to
pay her after using her services or
maybe even both regardless this was not
something Stroud was willing to let
slide he went to band Dharma's Shack to
confront him he was armed with a 38
caliber pistol he waited for the
bartender to arrive home and killed him
with a shot to the heart afterwards
Stroud turned himself in at the city
marshal his mother heard of what had
happened and hired a lawyer to defend
her son they were able to strike a deal
where Stroud would avoid a charge of
first-degree murder with the possibility
of the death penalty by pleading guilty
to manslaughter both mother and son were
hoping for a light sentence of only a
few years in prison but this was not to
be the federal judge who presided over
his case was named ie
he was new on the job and eager to show
everyone that he was hard on crime
particularly to those who used violence
in his jurisdiction
he saw Strout as the perfect man to make
an example out of so on August the 23rd
1909 Cushman sentenced him to the
maximum of 12 years to be served at the
McNeil Islands federal penitentiary
on the Puget Sound Straus didn't know it
yet but he would never see life outside
of a prison again
[Music]
robert stroud did not sin have a lot of
his sentence of McNeil Islands after his
arrival it didn't take long before he
developed a reputation with the gods and
the other inmates of being an angry and
dangerous man on one occasion he
assaulted a hospital orderly whom he
believed had reported Stroud's the
prison administration for trying to
obtain narcotics by using threats and
intimidation on another occasion Stroud
got into a fight and stabbed a prisoner
who allegedly ratted him out for
stealing food this attacker and Stroud
an additional six months added to his
sentence but he would not serve them up
McNeil instead in nineteen twelve Stroud
and dozens of other inmates were
transferred to a newer prison the
maximum-security Leavenworth federal
penitentiary in Kansas Leavenworth would
go on to become one of the most infamous
prisons in the country but at the time
it had only been opened for less than a
decade and some of the cell blocks were
still under construction
however this move was necessary due to
prison overcrowding
although Strout at left school at the
age of twelve he soon discovered that
his time behind bars represented a good
opportunity to continuous learning
he took various long distance courses
from the Kansas State Agricultural
College and excelled at most of them
despite his third-grade education
these included hard sciences like
mathematics structural engineering and
astronomy but also spiritual classes
like theosophy the progress Stroud was
making was derailed in 1915 when he was
diagnosed with Bright's disease an
illness that causes chronic inflammation
of the kidneys Stroud had struggled with
pain and the other symptoms for years
but it finally reached the points where
he became bedridden and for a while even
feared that he might die eventually he
started to slowly recover but he was
left weakened and gaunt not to mention
that the pain was still there there was
steadily turning Stroud into a more
bitter and angry man any hope that he
had of walking free went away the
following year after he killed again on
March 26 1916 Stroud attacked one of the
prison guards in the mess hall and
murdered him by plunging a butcher's
knife into his chest that guards name
was Andrew Tanner and the exact
circumstances behind his death are still
somewhat unclear some sources which are
more favorable to Stroud painted Turner
as an arrogant bully who enjoyed
taunting and exerting his authority over
the inmates
allegedly stroud became infuriated after
being denied the possibility to see his
brother who came to visit him for the
first time he started lashing out
verbally and Turner reported him which
caused the inmate to lose all of his
visiting privileges in turn this led to
the aforementioned altercation which
resulted in the guards death another
version of the story also mentions
Stroud as being enraged at not being
able to see his brother Turner
however only did something trivial by
telling the prisoner to stop talking in
the mess hall but this was enough to
make him snap and kill the guards in
front of over a thousand witnesses
obviously Stroud was found guilty of
first-degree murder in his first trial
he was sentenced to death by hanging
fortunately for him his mother had once
again
hired a good lawyer to defend him they
immediately filed an appeal and she
managed to get the trial invalidated on
a technicality Stroud was safe but only
temporarily as another trial was
scheduled for the following year
meanwhile Elizabeth Stroud was doing
everything she could on her end to save
her son she wrote to everyone who would
listen trying to get them on her side
and against the death penalty when the
time came for the second trial
Strauss lawyer used the insanity plea as
his defense arguing that his client was
mentally incompetent he also claims that
Stroud acted in self-defense as Turner
began attacking him with his club first
on May the 22nd 1917 Robert Stroud was
once again found guilty of Andrew
Turner's murder this time however he was
sentenced to life in prison and not the
death penalty Stroud was still not happy
with the result though it was he
believed that his defense had been
unable to present evidence which was
critical to his case he instructed his
lawyer to file an appeal again and the
trial was once more invalidated and a
new one was scheduled for the following
year the third trial did not go as
Stroud was hoping we're not sure if it
was because too much time had passed or
maybe annoyance that his clients had
filed for another appeal but Stroud's
lawyer lost interest in the case when
the hearing began he failed to show up
prompting the judge to disqualify him
and assign new lawyers to the defense
more than that Stroud discovered that
his lawyer had already negotiated with
the prosecution without his knowledge
agreeing to enter a guilty plea for sec
degree murder this was probably the best
he could have hoped for but Stroud still
protested the plea because it was done
without his approval given the new
circumstances the judge decided to delay
the trial for a few months in June 1918
the court proceedings resumed Stroud was
able to present all the new evidence and
witnesses that he wanted but surprise
surprise he was still found guilty of
first-degree murder not only that but
this time he was sentenced to death
again another appeal was filed by
Strauss lawyers and the Supreme Court
ordered a temporary stay of execution
while the case was analyzed however in
November 1919 the Supreme Court not only
upheld the decision but also disallowed
any further hearings on the matter
Robert Stroud's execution was scheduled
for April the 23rd 1920 at this point
those previous offers probably looking
pretty good
after the third trial had concluded
there was just one person
who had still not given up on Stroud is
not that in order to save her son
Elizabeth had to find a way to appeal to
a Power greater than the Supreme Court
there was only one solution executive
clemency she wanted to go straight to
the President of the United States and
ask for him to commute Robert's death
sentence at the time the president was
Woodrow Wilson but he was bedridden
following a stroke and his wife Edith
handled many of his duties she met with
Elizabeth Stroud in persons eventually
stopped the execution eight days before
it was scheduled to take place
the trials and appeals were over robert
stroud managed to escape the death
penalty but he was sentenced to spend
the rest of his life in solitary
confinement he was placed in the so
called isolation building at eleven
Werth where he had restricted contact
with people and could not move around
the prison grounds freely that being the
case the warden did allow Stroud to
continue his education and scientific
interests the prisoners life took a
significant turn for the better one day
in June 1920 when Stroud was out walking
through the exercise yard he had found
what remained of a nest which got blown
away during a storm the nest was
destroyed but it still contained three
live baby sparrows Stroud decided to try
and nurse them back to health and thus
the Birdman of Alcatraz was born as
you're about to see the Birdman of
eleven worth would have been a far more
appropriate name for him but I guess it
didn't have the same ring to it anyway
Stroud brought the three Sparrow chicks
to his cell improvised a nest and
started feeding his new roommates
so I've described this event as Stroud
finding a new lease on life as
ornithology became his new passion he
read all the books on the subjects that
he could get his hands on he learned how
to properly care for birds and was
allowed to keep Canaries fortunately for
Stroud's the warden was initially
pleased and even encouraged his new
interest it wasn't long before the
inmate started breeding his own Canaries
and even selling them to people who
visited the prison over the following
years the bird man's Avery had become
one of the main attractions at
Leavenworth at its height Stroud packed
in over 300 Canaries in his cell keeping
them in cages that he made out of cigar
boxes his business lasted until 1931
when a new ruling said that federal
prisoners were no longer able to conduct
for-profit enterprises while
incarcerated his day job may have gone
away but this did not dull Stroud's
enthusiasm for birds he simply focused
more on the theoretical sight being in
prison there were obviously still a lot
of things that Stroud could not obtain
so he improvised he studied pharmacology
and medicine so he could make his own
remedies and antiseptics when a bird
died he dissected it using his
fingernails
he began corresponding with thousands of
other breeders and bird experts and even
started writing articles that were good
enough to be published in journals one
of the people
Stroud corresponded with was a canary
breeder from Indiana
named della Mae Jones who had been very
impressed with the inmates
avy and know how soon enough she
started visiting Leavenworth to see
Strout and the two even launched a
business together selling his bird
medicine it did well but it only lasted
a short while before he was forced to
give it up in 1931 by this point it was
fair to say that the prison warden and
the entire Federal Bureau of Prisons for
that matter were growing tired of Stroud
and his birds and would have liked to
use this opportunity to get rid of them
altogether however the Birdman did not
take this decision lying down he and
Jones mostly Jones are for the young
honest began a letter-writing campaign
to raise awareness of his problem which
resonated with many other breeders and
bird lovers across the country Jones
obtained 50,000 signatures for a
petition which she sent to the President
of the United States we're not sure if
the president was ever actually made
aware of the issue but all the added
publicity was enough to get the Federal
Bureau of Prisons to back off it didn't
allow Stroud to make profits off his
business again but he could keep the
birds the scientific research and
equipment and he was even moved to a
bigger cell with the business side of
his career gone Strauss has nothing else
to do that concentrates on the research
he compiles everything he learns about
the death and disease of the birds that
he studied into a sixty thousand word
manuscript which he smuggled out of
prison in the outside world Jones helped
get it published in 1933 under the title
diseases of Canaries almost a decade
later he wrote and published Stroud's
Digest on the diseases of birds which
was more or less the same book with some
new and updated information
the original title from 1933 was
moderately successful and contained
plenty of useful information most of
which was still relevant today
however Stroud claims that he had been
cheated by his publisher and that he had
not received any royalties from the
sales
he used the only weapon he had at his
disposal public opinion he publicized
the issue which prompted his publisher
to complain to prison authorities who
again began looking for a way of making
the Birdman problem go away forever
allegedly this was the first time they
tried to have him sent Alcatraz but
Stroud managed to prevent it through a
legal loophole he learns that prisoners
had the right to remain in Kansas if
they were married to someone still
living in the state so later that same
year he and Ella Mae Jones tied the knot
apparently this enraged his mother we
cannot tell you why exactly
maybe she believed that women
were the source of all her son's
troubles or maybe she held him unhealthy
resentments for any other woman who was
part of Roberts life although she had
been his strongest supporter for decades
Elizabeth Stroud completely turned on
her son and even testified against him
at his first parole hearing in 1937
unsurprisingly parole was denied the
problems came one after another in the
years that followed first Stroud fell
ill and again it was serious enough that
it was thought he might die he recovered
but a few years later his world changed
forever
the prison board finally had the excuses
they needed to get rid of him on the
15th of December 1942 Stroud was woken
up early in the morning and told he was
being transferred to Alcatraz allegedly
Robert Stroud's only has 10 minutes
warning that he was being moved from
Leavenworth he had to leave behind all
his belongings which were sent to his
brother as for the exact reason it
wasn't really explained in details
citing merely a serious breach of prison
rules
supposedly Stroud stood accused of using
the special equipment he was afforded to
make moonshine or SHIVs for the other
inmates whether or not he actually did
this we're not sure but true or not is
allowed the Leavenworth officials to
unload one of their problem prisoners
Alcatraz had a much stricter set of
rules while Stroud was afforded some
privileges like correspondence access to
the library and even visitations he was
no longer allowed to keep birds that's
right
even though he is known as the Birdman
of Alcatraz Robert Stroud never actually
had any birds during the 17 years that
he spent imprisoned there instead he
kept on studying and writing supposedly
he learns multiple foreign languages
during his time there and he also
completed two new manuscripts one of
them was simply titled Bobby and it was
an autobiography of his life before
being incarcerated
the second was called looking outward a
history of the US prison system from
colonial times to the formation of the
Bureau of Prisons this one proved to be
much more problematic Stroud wanted to
publish it but his request was denied by
the director of the Federal Bureau of
Prisons the book who was deemed libelous
as it named multiple wardens and guards
and the illegal actions they were
allegedly involved in such as taking
bribes or beating up prisoners it was
also considered obscene as it contained
sexual content stroud filed a lawsuit
but actually died before a decision was
reached decades later his lawyer took up
possession of the manuscripts but still
couldn't find a publisher
it wasn't until just a few years ago
that some parts of the book were
published for the very first time back
in Alcatraz Stroud spent the first six
years in segregation in d-block for the
next 11 he was confined to the hospital
wing of the prison he kept writing
numerous petitions to the President to
the Supreme Court to the Attorney
General to anyone who could help him in
order to get a release but all of his
efforts failed he tried to commit
suicide once by overdosing on pain
medication but he didn't take enough
Robert Stroud was never able to get out
of prison but in his final years he got
the next best thing
due to his failing health in 1959 he was
transferred to the minimum-security
Medical Center for federal prisoners in
Springfield Missouri for a man who had
spent most of his life in solitary
confinement this was an almost unreal
experience he could walk the grounds at
his leisure he had a park where he could
spend his time he saw his first TV
program Stroud later concluded that he
saw more people and spoke more words in
the last few years in Springfield than
he did in the previous four decades of
his life by this point
Thomas Gaddis had already published his
book about him and work had begun on the
movie the Birdman of Alcatraz was one of
the most famous criminals in the country
and yet when Robert Stroud died on
November the 21st 1963 there were few
mentions of him asiya the unfortunate
timing of dying one day before the
assassination of President John F
Kennedy so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe also for more from
me why not check out that other channel
I mentioned at the beginning called
mega-projects I will link to that below
and thank you for watching
[Music]